uh any chance there's a multiverse in
which andrew garfield spider-man and
tony maguire spider-man and
your spider-man all meet together i mean
as a fan
hey everybody it's warren welcome back
to my channel the cosmic wonder where we
talk about things marvel and everything
marvel cinematic universe and of course
as always the big hype
right now is spider-man 3. now there are
some very exciting things coming up like
the release of the one of vision series
on disney plus happening january 15th
the hawkeye series
is filming right now and haley steinfeld
is confirmed to be playing kate bishop
and we have
many leaked photos and videos but no
matter what every day people are talking
about spider-man 3 and
the spider-verse now at this point it's
pretty much confirmed that it is in fact
going to be a spider-verse film we have
many different characters returning from
other universes
in fact there are going to be at least
five other characters from different
universes and i'll cover that in a video
later on but today we're going to talk
about the fact that tom holland
totally knew about the spider-verse
happening way back
in 2019 during the release of spider-man
far from home and today we have a video
that totally proves it
from jake hamilton and his channel
jake's takes and we're gonna break down
everything you need to know
be sure to subscribe if you're new so
you can stay up to date on all of the
latest mcu news and so you can enter
this week's giveaway for a chance to win
a zombie mysterio funko pop
so i'll link the full video to this down
below because we're going to talk about
a very specific part of this interview
with tom holland jacob babylon and
zendaya
with jake hamilton so in this interview
jake hamilton starts talking about into
the spider-verse and then he mentions
that spider-man far from home also kind
of talks about the multiverse which
they did mysterio did say that he was
from a different universe
and he even said earth 616 is the main
universe
now of course that ended up being a lie
but spider-man far from home did bring
up the multiverse but then jake goes on
to ask about the next spider-man film
and if there's any chance that we would
see
other spider-man show up uh any chance
there's a multiverse in which andrew
garfield spider-man and tony mcguire
spider-man and
spider-man all meet together clashing no
we don't
because and then you sort of just say
that everyone just comes from a
different universe
but would you want that though would you
want that's maybe that's a better
question yeah
would we want that i mean as a fan i
would
the thing about this film that's so
exciting right is we take spider-man and
europe and what's so cool about that is
we've never seen spider-man in europe
before now of course i'd love to make a
movie those guys it was
like oh we're so the junket answer that
would be amazing it would be really
really cool so he asked this question
and then it cuts to
jacob tom and zendaya and as he asks
this question you can look at tom's face
and he looks like he's absolutely
terrified that he's going to
accidentally spoil something for the
next spider-man film which is spider-man
3.
as jake is asking these questions he
starts fiddling around with his hands
he's playing with his thumbs
and it just looks like he's completely
freaking out and the reason he's
freaking out is because he knows he
knows that the next film was supposed to
be a spider-verse film
sony did into the spider-verse so it
would just make sense that they were
playing a live-action spider-verse for a
pretty long time as well
and as the interview goes on it becomes
fairly obvious that tom really is trying
not to spoil anything he doesn't even
answer the question
after jake asked the question tom
literally says nothing he's completely
silent while jacob and zendaya talk
about what that would be like
then ultimately jake would end up asking
him if his no answer is an
answer in and of itself then tom
completely ignores the question he says
the thing about this film speaking about
spider-man far from home the thing
that's so exciting is that we take
spider-man to europe and then he kind of
acts like he was kidding trying to avoid
the question but then he actually does
address
it and he gives a typical cookie cutter
answer of somebody who definitely knows
that it's happening but of course can't
reveal anything
but ultimately he does end up saying yes
that would be amazing
no it'd be amazing it would be really
really cool and it's something that the
fans
really want so whether marvel and sony
decide to do that
um or is it exciting to do it it's not
up to me i can't walk him like kevin
this is what we're doing on the next one
yeah
but it would be really awesome so this
is pretty funny i think it's hilarious
that
tom holland was asked this over a year
ago kind of froze on the spot because he
definitely knew that it was happening
but then played it off like
it was a cool idea but let's face it
when you have a movie that's as big as
this movie is going to be
the spider-verse a live-action
spider-verse and the multiverse
in the mcu you plan it for a very long
time it's not just
whipped together over the course of a
year or so and let's not forget that tom
holland's contract had three movies so
they definitely discussed the three
movies with him prior
so tom holland absolutely knew what was
going to happen down the road with his
spider-man
ultimately going on to meet up with the
other spider-man toby maguire's and
andrew garfield's
at some point in time in his spider-man
career and i'm really surprised that
jake hamilton is actually the only
person to really ask him in an interview
about this
of course everybody knows now it's no
surprise but it honestly is a pretty big
shocker that tom holland never spoiled
it
but recently we've been getting a lot of
spider-man 3 news so be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest news and look out for my
next video talking more about some
pretty big news about the spider-verse
hit the like button if you enjoyed this
video and for live updates you can
always follow me on instagram and
twitter as always thank you all so much
for watching
woof
you